if you recall the tragedy of heath
ledger in his posthumous oscar win you
might be surprised to learn he wasn't
the first to win the award after he died
a few other actors have also given
academy award-winning performances and
then passed away shortly after all these
actors are recalled for their great
award-winning performances in a career
spanning decades henry fonda left an
indelible mark on the history of
american cinema as one of the most
identifiable movie stars of his
generation an actor known for taking
roles that emphasized his own american
ideals fonda compiled a robust
collection of credits his best-known
films include young mr lincoln the
grapes of wrath and 12 angry men he also
launched the fonda acting dynasty which
includes his children jane and peter and
his granddaughter bridget despite his
many acting achievements much of fonda's
career went unnoticed by the academy he
was nominated for best actor for the
grapes of wrath in 1941 and nominated as
a producer for 12 angry men in 1958 but
has found to enter the 70s he had yet to
win an oscar that changed with on golden
pond in which he co-starred with fellow
screen legend catherine hepburn as an
aging couple trying to mend family
fences the film earned fonda and hepburn
best actor and best actress oscars
respectively giving fonda his first and
only oscar win he died of heart failure
just a few months later in august of
1982 at the age of 77. hepburn acted
only sporadically after on golden pond
and lived largely in quiet retirement
until her death in 2003
after beginning his career on the stage
and in radio peter finch built a
reputation as a powerful acting presence
on the big screen and by the 1950s he
was often running earning international
acclaim for films like a town like alice
the nun story and the trials of oscar
wilde today though finch is best
remembered for his role as howard beal
in the 1976 classic network biel a
devoted newsman who gross fed up with
his network's effort to put profit over
journalistic integrity allowed finch to
exercise every ounce of fiery energy he
had his delivery of one particular line
cemented his place in countless montages
of the greatest movie lines of all time
i'm as mad as hell and i'm not gonna
take this anymore
network was one of the most acclaimed
films of 1976 and it earned finch his
second oscar nomination sadly in january
of 1977 the day after he'd appeared on
the tonight show to promote the film
finch died after suffering a heart
attack in the lobby of the beverly hills
hotel he was 60. in the weeks after he
died his performance in network earned
him his first golden globe his fifth
bafta award and his first oscar for best
actor at the time of the award he was
the first actor to ever win a posthumous
oscar
in a career spanning five decades melvin
douglas did it all and to prove it he
remains one of only two dozen people to
ever complete the triple crown of acting
he won an emmy tony and oscars for his
performances across stage and screen
douglas began appearing in feature films
in 1931 and quickly established himself
as a suave quick-witted presence in
everything from the old dark house to
nanocha which remains one of his best
known roles today he worked regularly in
features throughout the 1930s and 1940s
and in the 1950s made the successful
leap to prolific television work in 1964
emitted returned to making movies
douglas won the oscar for best
supporting actor for his role as homer
bannon and hud that success led to
prolific work well into his 70s as he
continued to jump from big screen to
small and back again in 1980 douglas won
his second best supporting actor oscar
this time for his role as benjamin rand
and being there sadly douglas passed
away at the age of 80 in august of 1981
just over a year after his second oscar
win
some actors spend their entire career
sitting in the shadow of the oscars
almost touching that golden statue but
never quite grasping it despite decades
of tantalizing near misses that was the
case for geraldine page an actress who
began building a name for herself on the
stage in the 1940s paige gained academy
attention at the very beginning of her
film career earning the best supporting
actress nomination for her role opposite
john wayne in hondo another six
nominations followed with no award
including best actress for summer and
smoke sweet bird of youth and interiors
and best supporting actress for europe
big boy now pete and tilly and the pope
of greenwich village then at last came
paige's part in the trip to bountiful
paige's performance as an aging woman
who wants nothing more than to return to
her rural home after years away earned
her some of the best reviews of her
career she received golden globe and
bafta nominations and she finally earned
the oscar for best actress in 1986.
sadly her post-oscar career was
short-lived on june 13 1987 paige was
found dead in her apartment at the age
of 62 after an apparent heart attack
for actors of all ages an academy award
is supposed to be a gateway to a wider
world of acting options it's a rocket
you can ride to whatever opportunities
you choose that should have been the
case for marie dressler and even though
she didn't die immediately after winning
her oscar what happened in the aftermath
did cut her time tragically short like
many performers during this period of
time the changing hollywood landscape
proved challenging for dressler she
spent much of the 1920s without being
able to book a single film role finally
after struggling financially for years
the late 1920s and the introduction of
sound brought about a career renaissance
for her in 1932 dressler won the academy
award for best actress for min and bill
a victory that seemed primed to catapult
her to even greater stardom she launched
into more major films including emma and
dinner at eight but by 1932 she'd
received a critical cancer diagnosis her
health slowed her work to a crawl and
she died in july of 1934 at the age of
65.
we can trace one of the great filmmaking
dynasties in all of hollywood back to
walter houston he spent two decades
working steadily as a character actor
and starting the houston line of family
filmmakers it's perhaps only fitting
then that the film for which houston
finally won his oscar ended up being a
family affair in the treasure of the
sierra madre written and directed by a
son houston played howard an old-time
gold prospector who leads two younger
collaborators in a search for treasure
walter houston won the oscar for best
supporting actor for his performance as
howard his son john won the only two
oscars of his long career for best
director and best adapted screenplay for
the film sadly walter houston completed
just three more films before he died in
april of 1950 at the age of 67.
few actors in hollywood's silent era
were lucky to survive the paradigm
shifting transition to talkies at all
but a lucky few were able to thrive in
both eras alice brady was one of them
against all odds born into a theater
family the actress began her career on
the stage before starting to build her
silent film resume in 1914 she worked
steadily for several years before
leaving the screen to focus on her stage
work by the time she returned to the
movies in 1933 hollywood had changed
dramatically but brady's talent was
still there she picked up right where
she had left off launching a career in
the sound era that included roles in the
gay divorcee gold diggers of 1935 and my
man godfrey for which she was nominated
for an oscar in 1937. just a year later
in 1938 brady received her second oscar
nomination for an old chicago but the
afterglow was to be short-lived brady
was diagnosed with cancer and died in
october of 1939 at the age of 46.
even before his big oscar buzz heath
ledger was widely recognized as one of
the most promising young actors of his
generation his career launched on
australian television in the 1990s and
he was an instant success when he began
appearing in american films like 10
things i hate about you and the patriot
by the mid-2000s he was a full-fledged
movie star and in 2005 alone he appeared
in casanova the brothers grimm lords of
dog town and brokeback mountain he
received golden globe bafta and oscar
nominations for his performance in the
last film making him one of the youngest
oscar nominees in history then came the
dark knight cut off the success of
batman begins director christopher nolan
cast ledger has his incarnation of the
joker while fans skepticism was
initially high buzz from the set and
early looks at the character quickly
built excitement for a potentially
iconic piece of superhero work
sadly ledger did not live to see the
full response to the film he died in
january of 2008 at the age of just 28
after an accidental overdose in his new
york city apartment months before the
dark knight was set to premiere when the
film finally hit theaters ledger
received near universal acclaim for his
performance and earned posthumous bafta
golden globe and oscar wins for best
supporting actor that made him only the
second actor ever in history to win an
oscar after his death